[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
what's going on you guys gaming out here
coming at you for another lord addict
here coming at you with another attic
show
uh as you can see we are a full house
today we got we got
my co-host hustle motivate what's going
on hustle
uh not much not much but friday i do
believe you are playing revenge of
shinobi correct
uh yeah well look that's pending that's
pending right now okay all right all
right well you know just look whenever
you get to it just know that the
gentleman behind me
hearing about no games that's all i'm
saying are you are you gonna keep
switching your background depending on
what i'm playing that week
yes sir yes sir this is promotion right
here this is a trollin
okay i know what i call it i mean nah
nah nah but um i look forward to that um
i know we're gonna talk about some
interesting topics today i would say one
controversial snub and i i can't wait to
get into it uh it's the photo finish boy
i ran up in the house brushed my teeth
used the bathroom i said all right i'm
here i said i'm here
let's go
yo your photo finish a little bit
different than mine but the same thing
and we got the one
the only
king david how you doing man how you
doing i'm doing fantastic um i am the
xbox swami
if you guys don't know me or haven't
heard of me you'll learn about me uh
twitter knows me and they know not to
bother me but um my photo finish i'm
laying on my bed uh just twinkling my
toes
looking up at the ceiling feeling all
types of rested because you know the
wife and i went had some wonderful lunch
oh my god you know eggs benedict is
delicious
absolutely delicious so you know like
every once in a while we like to go out
and and reset and talk and look into
each other eyes and all that wonderful
stuff that i suggest everyone do
and um
she's like what you got to do today i
said oh i got a podcast but at it she's
like oh god what are you turning into
james brown
i said no but you know um we're doing
the um the gaming awards stuff so she
was like all right cool cool cool so get
home get my rest and i'm thinking we're
going at six o'clock
and yeah my times was off so i had a
photo finish as well
yeah i hear you man you know
got a little bit of the little bit of
the miscommunication going on there
what's funny is there was a time today
where i thought king might over sleep
and i thought hustle ain't going to be
here so i was about to come here zolo
dolo man i was about to do the whole
show by myself
you're doing it right now
frozen frozen
you want to build a snowman
i think i think it's obs messing with it
but anyway
i know how to fix that problem oh you
know how to fix it awesome yes sir you
use the cam link right
yes same same thing with king with the
same reason why king was being frozen
you the cam link is a bandwidth hungry
for usb 3.0 so whatever you got plugged
in i said you unplug everything but i'm
saying that you got to make sure that
that's one of their priorities just so
it's around
yeah yeah so you just got to kind of see
what working with them i went through
that when i first started streaming um
yeah my point in shoot too so that's
nice so i'll definitely uh look into
that after the show until then i'm gonna
have i'm gonna have to prevent the
the playstation fanboys from turning my
mic on my my camera off man they do
whatever they can because they know
that uh it's about to get a little messy
do they know they know that so let's
let's go ahead and get straight into the
show man uh you know first thing i want
what do you guys want to talk about
first elder scrolls 6 or the video game
awards
oh man well if we got to pick one i mean
we can get elder scrolls out the way
because i you know yeah
because all right all right so let's go
ahead and get that is that cool with you
king is that cool with you let's get out
i thought the guests get a chance to
pick because you know me personally just
me personally
i want to get into the controversy and
the extra message because see listen
elder scrolls this that's a locker right
we already locked into that right so
we're gonna get them later let's just
warm them up for the beat down right
let's just start off with the stuff that
they don't know about how the left hook
go hit him right so i'm good with this
part um but
no i'm here sir so whatever you want to
start off with attic the floor is yours
you're in hustle i'm just
the humble guest
all right so so what we'll do is we'll
go ahead and get this elder scrolls six
out the way because i have a feeling
that video game award is about to be a
very hot topic like i i've already seen
people upset on twitter man people are
are going crazy on twitter but let's go
ahead and get this elder scrolls because
i think we all knew this but guess what
king now they know this so
phil spencer came out there and he kind
of uh he didn't really elude he just
straight up pretty much said the reason
why these games were going exclusive and
he used the particular game elder
scrolls 6 as an example and when you saw
this king let's go to king first because
me and king have been saying this for
the longest
when you first saw this king how what
was the first thought process that were
behind your mind
well when i first saw it i was like man
he is so nice you know he's so cool
because what my mother used to say is
because i said so like
so what i really want to hear him say is
like yes
excuse me why is elder scrolls a sex
exclusive because i said so like
yeah i think cause i said so i think it
would have hit so much harder and it
would have put so much fear because when
my mother said cause i said so the level
of fear that was inside my soul was
different and i don't think they they
understand fear so i think we have to
introduce a level of fear into them and
i think because i said so would have
definitely did that
you know like
why why why can't we have it because i
said so like because i said so has a
whole different kind of feeling to it
now but in all seriousness what did they
think
seven point uh something billion dollars
on a whole company you didn't buy one uh
aspect of the company you know you went
there and got the whole kit in caboodle
so when you're going i mean from mobile
games to cloud gaming to to the whole
infrastructure
at zenimax that wasn't bethesda they
keep on saying bethesda it's xenomax and
you just because their little minds
can't grasp what xenomax is it
encompassed one aspect of the company is
bethesda that's one one aspect that they
understood so
when he said you know because i said so
well he didn't say that that's that's
what i heard
but
i just felt that it just needs to be
said and
we're at a point now what every game
that's announced is gonna be because i
said so type of thing
it shouldn't be like that but
it was because he wasn't clear in the
beginning with their legacy stuff
when you say legacy and they're trying
to figure out what games fall under his
connotation of legacy it's always going
to leave people at a guessing game type
of situation so he's going to have to
revisit this every single time a
different game comes out and that was a
monster of his own manifest so
if he would have said from the beginning
you don't get anything unless i choose
to because i said so and that would have
stopped everything at that moment but
we're at this point and he's gonna learn
and i can't wait for that day when he's
tired and he said cause i said so you
ain't getting it
yeah i agree with you i feel like
it's very clear that this is happening
and the funny part
is just how many
people keep asking that man this like
it's like every time someone does an
interview with them
what about elder scrolls six look in my
mindset and i think you guys would agree
if they're willing to put something as
the caliber as starfield a new ip
something that is brand new
that they haven't made a new iep in this
long i'm pretty sure
elder scrolls six is up for is up on the
chopping block that that's definitely
going to be an exclusive like king said
earlier you don't spend 7.5
billion with a b i know some of you
don't know the b word but billion with a
b and then you still let that stuff come
on the uh you know the the competitive
platform hustle how do you feel about
this is are you about the same snare but
did this shock you
no no it didn't shock me um what shocks
me a little bit is the fact that people
keep asking is this going here is this
going there and can you brought it up
earlier it's only because the messaging
wasn't clear in the beginning um and
technically elder scrolls is a legacy
title like an old dome and like all
those other like services service games
like that not doing but just like the
elder scrolls stuff like that
yeah i mean i i wouldn't have asked if
if i were them but i i think i feel like
you should know by now like that's a lot
of bread though they didn't just buy the
you know the office they didn't just buy
the building they bought the whole block
but thinking about the whole state we
being that that's a whole lot of bread
dog so like i feel like we need to throw
all those questions out the window i
feel like from here on out anytime that
we get something new
we know where is that and hold on and we
know where it's not going unless you
know
worldwide gym as you affectionately call
them king um unless that man won't put
xbox uh game pass on playstation nah
they ain't getting that joint same thing
with nintendo yeah yep wow before like
how's that gonna benefit them yeah we
here for the players but we also wanted
to make this money back so
come on with it you know but they know
what it is man and plus they they the
guy to keep
the brand of xbox i got to make sure it
has as much value as possible because
the brand of xbox is going to get the
more game pass subscriptions it's going
to get them
more sales in general it's going to make
that you know
their presence in the gaming industry
more and i think that you know if it's
not clear now i know a lot of people try
to use the legacy thing and try to wing
with that but legacy really meant just
existing titles they're going to make
sure they're continuously updated and
for example like let's say far cry 3
gets a remake that most likely would go
on the uh the playstation platform but
they make a far cry they make a
fallout five fallout yeah yeah they're
not going to be doing any that's an xbox
and pc exclusive that's not going on the
competing platform and i think phil
spencer
it's been very
iffy off he wants to answer that or not
but i think this was very clear
don't expect my stuff on your platform
if you want my stuff
come over where i live
i don't live in new york anymore i live
in new jersey come over here
and i i think that's the best way that
that it needs to go because at the end
of the day you got to give the platform
a lot of uh you know a lot of value a
lot of diversity and if it's on other
platforms sure you'll still get the
platform diversity because the game pass
but it's not going to hit is that much
and i think that you know
i love that they were very open with
this and you know clearly you're already
seeing people trying to twist his words
again we're not going to get too much
into that but you know that's we can
leave that in the past man i hope we
don't have to talk about that much any
further
let's go
to
the video game awards all right
what we're gonna do
is we're going to i'm gonna put it up on
the screen
uh because there's a couple chatters no
we're not gonna go over all these
categories because a lot of them isn't
really important to be real with you but
we're all gonna go over a couple of them
and um you know do you guys have the
link or do i need to give you guys the
link real quick
oh i'm gonna open it on our screen
yeah yeah so um i will
drop it in the chat
yeah give me a second appreciate you
and while we're doing that i do want to
shout out a few people in the chat i see
blade x i see uh my favorite skeleton
himself citizen sleeve what up boy oh
let's see i see i be
blip i believe i've never seen you
before um hey it's good to see y'all man
um hey y'all let us know how y'all feel
about the uh the recent announcement
from phil spencer man i see a few things
in the chat
i i'm here for it i'm just gonna keep it
real for you man i'm here because they
spent all that money man you got to go
get it thank you for that lingerie
appreciate you all right so the this
we're going to work our way up a little
bit we're only going to get the
important stuff i don't really want to
go over the stuff that no one's really
going to really care about
uh so you know this best esports event
nope this best esports coach nope this
is only going to win all of those yeah
they got don't they own like esports
um they own the fighting thing whatever
that oh fgc yep yeah they own that xbox
owned crunchyroll no i'm just joking
you know it's crazy king they're
actually doing like crunchyroll
and gameplay
so let's go over this all right so let's
first one most anticipated game
you know what's funny
is what these are always like really
weird so eldon ring god of war ragnarok
horizon forbidden west the sequel to
legend
uh the sequel to the the legend of zelda
breath of the wild and starfield
i would love for star fo to win this i'm
gonna be real with you i would love for
star foe to win this but i think it's
probably gonna go to god of war ragnarok
i think it's pretty safe to assume that
it nor do you guys think it might go to
like eldon ring
oh no oh no i don't think it's gonna go
to elven ring i think um out of zelda
um
you know um the breath of the wild and
uh
god of war ragnarok
is out of those two um because
verizon i mean a lot of these games is
uh pc games um
except for
uh you know zelda
um so
i think the fomo is to be higher than uh
the breath of the wild to be honest with
you i really think breath of the wild
might take it because out of all those
games there
i would be more anticipating the breath
of the wild opposed to anything there
like if i had a choice to spend my money
on anything there
it would be breath of the wild and i'm
just talking from my standpoint
um the pc dudes will get a chance to
taste everything there but breath of the
wild
um
dudes i am absolutely trolling you so
hard right now
um
playstation
clarify
yeah king you're saying that god war in
that forbidden west that's touching pc
oh yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah worldwide gym definitely believe
that's going to straight to the pc
because they definitely got to get that
money man so um yeah no 100
all that stuff is pc stuff uh xbox and
pc we already know what xbox is with i
honestly would bet my money on that one
aspect of it where i can't get it and i
have to get it from one place it will
definitely go to zelda breath and while
being a breath of the wild sold with the
console and one-on-one ratio um
god of war didn't do that horizon didn't
do that eldon rings the new ip and so is
starfield so those two is iffy um
yeah i'm gonna go with breath of the
wild
that's what's up so let me get this
super chat real quick from the two
dollar superchat from j nicholas game of
the year psychonauts 2. jay we're going
to get to that game of the year man
we're going to get to that i have a
feeling
that's going to be the craziest topic of
today's show so okay now we ain't doing
best uh debut indy and i know that that
is worth doing but i don't think for
this show because i want to make sure
that uh iop does a show where we really
break this down and i don't want to go
too much into that because then mike you
know king might give the other lords
what we picking you know what i'm saying
like we ain't trying to do that
so you know let let's go to base best
racer
and best
uh sports game and fourth horizon five
does not win this i'm a revolt
so let me let me go let me break it down
for you guys man so it's f1 2021 does
anyone even know what that game is
no
uh i know it's formula one but i have
not played that
yeah so we got that we got fifa 2022
we got four as a horizon five which
should be in the game of the year
nominations but we're gonna move past
that too we got hot wheels unleashed and
we got writer's republic
oh
really so
yeah that's kind of crazy
i think
we all know what's winning this and you
know what's crazy the fact that forza
can get into this one but not game of
the year
no that's that's the little caveat bs
let me throw them a bone type of uh
situation because we don't want this one
game to come disrupt our whole shmo
so
yeah
and i thought the hot wheels stuff was
on
uh forza horizon 4.
that's i could have sworn it was like a
hot wheels package that dealer was
playing i saw dilla playing it
i thought it was the lego pack that was
when that they had a lego pack too
okay all right so they didn't have a hot
wheels pack because remember they had
the hot wheels track and i remember the
orange thing that was going all the way
around and getting that loop-de-loop and
stuff like that i mean correct me if i'm
wrong
yeah chad correct me if i'm wrong didn't
they have um a hot wheels uh situation
on um forza horizon four
uh i don't know um
definitely if if the chat knows that uh
you know tell us because i
they're what i'm pretty sure there was a
fours i just don't remember exactly like
if it was in four
yeah
they just need to ring that rename this
uh best uh sportsman racing they just
need to rename this to forza award dog
like
like you know how nintendo has their own
category for like the best family
friendly games and it's all nintendo
games just just rename this like the
xbox category or something though cause
i i there is no way that none of any of
these other games are winning especially
fifa given the controversy that they've
been going through with everything
that's been going on on that answer like
yeah i mean i'll tell you i'll take four
to on that five days a week playground
name really missed yet like when did
they start with this was it horizon 2 i
think
they they really missed so
if i got to pick something to go with it
yeah so if i got to pick something to go
but i'm going uh four to five for the
most part i can't agree with everything
in this list this list right here this
particular list
um i personally feel like
these two should be separated but i
don't know if there's enough racing
to separate that every year
so maybe that's why they don't separate
them i don't know but you know it is
what it is we ain't gonna go too much
into that
um
best fighter i don't think we really
want to talk about best action game
all right this is interesting back for
blood chivalry two oh king chivalry too
far cry six
and return
oh
okay so
out of all of these kids is doing their
own thing one of these kids is one of
the same
one of these kids is doing his own thing
now it's time to say his name out of all
these games which one ship broken so
it's not it's not uh
far cry 6 it's not def loop it's not
chivalry too it's not back for blood oh
it's that broken game so let's move that
to the side um you're not winning best
action if we can't uh play
i'm about to uh i'm about to be extra
man i know i shouldn't do this but i'm
about to entertain everything you say
all right so let's let's uh go ahead and
uh let's
let's get rid of return i'm gonna remove
it off the screen yeah all right
um
far cry 6 uh dealer can't stop talking
about it deal i know your ears are
ringing i'm talking about you today
you're my barometer of uh great games so
all right so far cry 6 is is pretty good
i personally would love to root for def
loop uh for def loop to win best action
game in this genre
only because it's a win for microsoft i
mean that's the absolute slam dunk home
so it's bittersweet on the playstation
and and i'm being petty um chivalry too
it is so much fun because i actually
played it with the team you can go check
that out on this on on iron lord's
channel uh where we play this game and
it was absolutely so much fun all the
lords was getting in on that um back
foot blood is my personal choice because
i think that game has so much to offer
uh it's i thought it was going to be
like um an extension of left 4 dead
and it's its whole entity with keeping
some of the dna from uh left 4 dead so
my personal pick will be back for blood
my petty pick is def loop and um
my team pick would be chivalry
but if i had to take my own money and i
had to bet i'm going to go with back for
blood for my own personal reasons i
think it's between chivalry too and back
for blood what do you feel hustle
well the game that i want to win um
we'll now win
it won't it's fraternal this is the only
game that i have oh my god on this list
adam you know i'm not good at this game
however however i see a lot of appeal in
the roguelike genre even though i'm not
good at it i see a lot of appeal in it
and i i think it's going to be uh
if fraternal does win
and we see def looping because i think
def loop was actually going to win this
category i think definitely might win
well never mind shout out hustler you're
moving too fast you move too fast
if if returners somehow wins best action
game but isn't nominated for game of the
year then i think we have to maybe not
question jeff kelly but i think we gotta
kind of question the people who are
voting at this point
uh it's
it's
some strong claims i i am i am because
it says a lot that that title is here
but not in the game of the year
in that game of the year contention
that's just it's just odd to me that's
all i'm saying i'm gonna leave it saying
leave it at that it's odd to me but um
if you can read tea leaves you can read
the tea leaves def loop is definitely
going to win this category um i think
i think shiver it are back for blood and
the reason i think that is because i
think
i think death loop and far cry 6 are
going in return gonna win other
categories so i think they're going to
give it to one of these two because i i
do feel like a lot of this is politics
gaming policy yes
i've always noticed that if something
wins something else
then
usually they give another category to
something that wouldn't have won those
anyway
yeah but addict i want you to think
about this for a second this is the best
action game
and the you know the game is in here
that's not the fraternal
no i got you i got you i mean whatever
you think whatever but what i'm saying
is one of the nominees for game of the
year is in the category for best action
category let's just put it this way
if def loop doesn't win this then it
shouldn't win game of the year based off
of what we see here that's all i'm
saying that's all i'm saying that's all
i'm saying i'll leave it at that it has
to be it has to win its own category to
actually yeah
i do get that because if you don't win
the best action game but to me maybe
death loop wouldn't win beck's action
game because it might be a phenomenal
action game but something maybe like far
cry 6 comes off just a little bit ahead
of it but in general
death loop is a better game overall than
not just like some of its core gameplay
maybe you know
mechanical features maybe the way the
game looks you know i i don't
necessarily i agree with some aspect of
that but i don't agree with
everything so i i it's like i said i
think it's back for blood
and i i think mainly it's because
they're going to do something like that
now we can't get this best indie because
uh death store i'm sure is going to be
in here
12 minutes
death store
insidious insidion
and
i do whatever this is
uh kenneth bridges spirits and loop hero
hustle what do you think's what in this
this is a good
category this is a really good category
so so i've only played an hour of uh
kenneth bridges spirits i really i
didn't like it too much i appreciate
what it means to have two black creators
make something that well it may not
necessarily be perfect i can understand
it on that level
12 minutes was was highly anticipated
but we haven't heard anybody talk about
it
you know since it's released and
released in august of this year for
people who don't know i think we sold
like the last week of august and once it
dropped
was it like a week later that joint was
you know the tumbleweeds when they
really heard
much about it death's
seems like the
i want to say the xbox legend of zelda
but like the
the pc like legend of zelda type game
that'll probably take that over um that
was made by two developers and i think
it's like 15 bucks on steam i thought it
was in game pass it's not there when i
checked it on pcs
i thought it was in the game that's why
i went that's why i went and got back on
game fast it's not this so i'm gonna go
cop there probably next weekend or
something but i feel like this is gonna
get passed this way
i mean it comes out in game pass and
then i mean you should have a crazy
backlog it comes out in game pass you
get the ten percent off then you buy it
now come on respect your dollars well
hold on hold on king uh one game that
we'll talk about a little bit later kind
of has all of my attention and focus
all right all right chill chill talking
about what's going on
uh-oh uh-oh all right all right no but i
think that's though we'll take a best in
the i'm glad we went over this
what's uh real quick what's loop hero
i've no i've not heard it loop here not
a roguelike yeah it's a rogue it's
actually a really good game i wouldn't
be surprised if it wins this
um
because i don't know what
it's either between lupiro kenna or
death's door i don't think 12 minutes is
winning that i don't think whatever that
other game's winning that it's between
those three they might give it to
kenneth because
we all know
jeff liked that jeff liked the
playstation brand so so
you might give it to canada because of
that it can't it's not like ken wouldn't
deserve it i do think
it's really between kenneth and death's
door and i think either one of those
deserve this but i think it might lean
more towards kenneth i think death thor
gets it
oh death thor gets it yeah i think i
think uh
from what i've heard
um i haven't every time i hear somebody
say something about kenneth can it is
nice kenneth is this but can as nice ken
as this butt you know and then every
time i hear death door game of the year
my man you gave me you have a point
there you do have a point though have
you played it my man game of the year
and i'm like yeah i'm holding out for
game pass yo it's just
when you didn't get in there man it's
just like hades man you gotta get in
there man so i'm gonna go with
everybody's opinion i value everborn's
opinion everborn has been championing
this game k asante has been championing
this game anybody that has touched their
fingers on this game has been yelling at
me like why didn't you buy it and you
listen you just heard hustle just say yo
i'm gonna go pick it up and i'm not
gonna wait for game pass and get the 10
off
even though he's playing something
that's crazy right now that this game
might not get uh his attention
but again um
i'm gonna go with what i can hear the
consensus is i haven't heard anybody say
after they play candy yo my man game of
the year you gotta get this not one
person i heard is a good game but
yeah i agree with you uh there is a lot
of uh 12 minutes is a good game but i i
do feel like there is a lot of
yeah there is a but but there is a lot
of
issues that that game has i didn't beat
that store i
i played like six hours of it or four or
five but
death's door
was a legit game i didn't really see any
issues with that story i'm real with you
on that man look hero is fun too i
honestly think loop here looks like a
better game than kenna because i played
loop here and i actually really enjoyed
loop hero and nothing about kenneth
appeals to me i don't like that game
so i can't wait to get it when it comes
out
hold on not even the artwork oh not even
like the graphics on it no those trees
gotta be moving man we're gonna move on
all right so best ongoing game isn't
that the one destiny's always in uh
destiny's not in it this year that's
interesting
okay so best ongoing games apex legends
final fantasy
14 online fortnite gentian impact and
call of duty war zone
all right uh we're gonna we're gonna
start with with
with
king
king fortnite do you
do you have an issue with with these
choices
not one issue with any of these games so
you don't think that's that he shouldn't
have been on here
look how strong these games are
apex
yeah look how strong these games are i'm
be real with your chief i think that uh
call of duty should replace destiny
nah
i'm gonna tell you right now um
contrary to popular belief brother
that call of duty war zone is out here
cracking foreheads
so um what about sea of thieves it's
been really good why yeah yeah the
millions play it man but again
you got to talk about what these little
millennials and these little generations
z's and y's and k's are doing
yeah
this generation wild style these dudes
is crazy um but um
yeah i have no problem with none of this
stuff uh people are finally learning
about fantasy star
um it's been around forever and i think
fantasy star bumped destiny out of this
list i mean final fantasy yeah this year
so i'm actually going to go with
fortnite here gation impact is really
really good um if i out of all these
games here
and i would play them in this order i
would play call of duty war zone um
because every time i played it i loved
it um then i would uh go over the um
apex legends
when i played it i love it uh fortnite
is just because i'm bending the knee i
have a problem with the company because
of what they did to pub g uh developers
um gation impact which is pretty good
would fall last on this list because
final fantasy will get the legacy nod
from me so if i'm really having to pick
myself i would go with call of duty war
zone but i know fortnight is such a
beast and it's such a animal i would
fortnite wins this category
i would now if we're going off what i
would play i would play apec legends
before anything else on this list
because i'm not the biggest call of duty
fan
i do think that war zones better than
the average call of duty game but that's
not saying much to me i'll be wrong
an impact
this is you know i'm looking at these
king
crown your lord gonna be tough this year
because like i'm looking at this and i'm
like any one of these can get it like i
would probably vote for final fantasy on
this yeah because it's been such a huge
phenomenal this year but gentian impact
has been a huge thing too so like
it's it's going to be interesting man we
got
we got a 5 super chat from
uh atticus
i don't know man we're gonna move past
that though coach said it best that uh
coach said it best that keeley didn't
even talk about the success of forza and
didn't acknowledge xbox anniversary but
did the playstation laugh out loud i'm
pretty sure you said laugh out loud all
right
so i'm not going to go too much into
this
it is not
his responsibility to hype a brand he
doesn't really rep
if that man don't want to come out and
say anything positive about the xbox
brand that's his decision i do think it
is a little weird that you you're
playing it you're not talking about it
but you tweet about everything else but
it's not his responsibility
to tweet about the xbox brand
but i'm gonna leave it at that you guys
got anything to address with that super
chat
um i don't have anything to address with
the super chat but i will say best one
going game i feel like apex legends is
kind of going to take that one home in
my opinion against an impact my homies
at the disrespected podcast like they
they over and that a lot shout out to my
homie alton man prezi they be doing
their thing over there
ain't really my cup of tea fortnite is
fortnite and uh given the recent um
travis scott events i don't think that
they will win that based off of optics i
mean i got my conspiracy theorists hat
on just because y'all don't know um it's
ten follow tenfold all around my room
right now um let's see
final fantasy
i think addie attitude mentioned earlier
final fantasy got a whole lot of shine
this year from a whole bunch of
different streamers uh say friend of the
show uh my boy kw fang he'll play that
he'll stream it i'll see the uphill in
like the final fantasy joint but but
that's me that's me but i think um i
like to shoot him up bang bang you know
and that and all that color
yeah man hey listen listen call of duty
to me respectfully if it has a story i
don't know it cause i'm not gonna follow
all that i just ain't with that apex
legends i don't know if it's ever won in
the world for best one going game but i
think it's time um you guys have
mentioned destiny earlier right
do y'all think that
you know regardless if did has this
category ever had any repeat winners i
want to lean on you two and i want to
you know everybody in the chat to
educate me
because if it happens
fortnite i think fortnight's wanted a
couple years hasn't it king
what won it last year
that changes everything doesn't it
but i don't think fortnite had like this
is the first year that i don't think
fortnight has had a like a lasting
effect something like final fantasy or
against an impact i do think it's a
contender and if it won it wouldn't
surprise me but i do think this is one
of the first years that if it didn't win
i would it wouldn't surprise me either
yeah
i feel like
i need to be careful saying this
i don't want to say that it's falling
off or it's losing his luster but it
kind of cuz like my nephew god bless him
dead boy he played that joint every day
when he getting this joint man like he
he can't like i said you don't want to
play that nose now fortnite fortnight
now that all right man so i don't know
so the kids don't like it let me just
say that my son plays it all the time he
just grinded to get some uh shotgun
that's in the game i'm i'm gonna tell
you right now
if it's gone by popularity
that's a
different monster up there
so shout out to the 300 plus people in
here uh definitely hit that like button
if you guys don't mind man let's get
those likes up but uh we're going to go
ahead and move on with this category i
do think this is going to be a really
interesting category i'm kind of curious
on who wins that uh best performance
so uh we got the
uh the main character from life is
strange true colors
we got the main uh antagonist from far
cry 6.
we got the we got colt from death loop
the main protagonist from there
we got the chick that played uh lady uh
demistress from resident evil village
and we've got
and then we got the other person the uh
the the chick that played
julian in death loop
uh i actually think death loop's gonna
win this i know
i think one of these characters it might
be the chick i think that chick
definitely might win this uh she played
a phenomenal character in death loop uh
i think i'm the only one on the panel
that's really played death loop like
that uh adam out of all these people
king who do you think might win this
john carlo esposito
oh he is the most distinguished person
on this list no disrespect no shade to
anybody here i've been riding with john
carlo esposito since uh him and spike
lee back in the days
um i've watched this scent of this man
and his insertion into our uh chosen
medium
which is uh video games and he has
landed in this medium
tip top form in this far cry 6
all the way from the mandalorian this
guy has permeated every aspect of what i
feel is our culture
i think it is hard to deny him his
performance
uh even from the trailers that we did
see
his level of performance was so gravitas
so so so controlling
that it made you say man i gotta see
what this dude is about this dictate
wild crazy with his son do you drop the
grenade down on these dudes heads or or
what so um like i'm getting goosebumps
right now thinking about the trailer i
gotta go with giancarlo esposito in this
not taking any shade away because i
definitely will win for the big girl and
um
uh
in resident evil
i want to play the game just for her um
but no john carl esposito without a
shadow of a doubt for me
um
what do you think hustle
well i mean
i would say john carlo is a shoot-on but
since king already picked this this fine
gentleman you took us all the way back
to with the spike lee reference are you
you're showing up
yeah you remember him you stepped on my
my my
my jaws like his face wait
that's him yes you go back and look at
it he was on the stoop with them i know
that
okay my fault we just let's do the right
thing y'all yes i didn't know that
no i didn't know that
oh my i'm old too i'm old too yeah sorry
um
all right well far cry 6 is far cry 6
he's a trained actor he's supposed to
run away with this addict you're going
to have to speak more to me about uh
death loop in the performances about the
two uh actresses
um everybody seems to like lady d um
everybody in our community
no no no
everybody seems to love her but i i do
want to um
uh speak about miss alex chen um
yes you know life is strange man like
those she might win that i don't think
people need
i don't think people need to sleep on
her she might win that
that that's exactly my point man i think
i think it's i don't think that she runs
away with that in particular but i feel
like if you haven't played the life of
strange or hell even if you want to
watch it and just listen to how she get
down yeah their voice actors always seem
to do their thing i think the first life
of strange that i played was on ps4
and i remember because i didn't finish
the whole thing i finished that first
episode i remember how strong like those
characters were chloe and i forget the
other young ladies name but i remember
how strong those characters were and um
erica here is no different or excuse me
alex there is no different part of me i
don't think this is any different man i
i think there's a lot to like take in um
i do want you to uh educate me on jason
kelly as a cult in our deaf loop i know
you said that um
miss blake i'm gonna go about her
character name because i'm gonna tear
her first name up i'm gonna tear her
first name adam last name up i know that
you said the antagonist in
def loop was really good so can you you
know just kind of go over that a little
bit can you summarize so so pretty much
colt and juliana the whole game
like
death loop is about continu is like
reliving the same day over and over
again
and the only people that recognize that
they're living the same day over and
over again is colt and juliana
and
cole juliana his purpose in the game is
to kill colt because he's trying to
break the loop
so
every day you start she's running her
mouth saying oh that didn't work did it
and then he'll he'll make like these
statements like oh you know and then
like the more you start to succeed the
more she starts flipping out so like
there'll be occasional spots where coats
like oh i didn't do that last time did i
she'll have like like a science he's
like oh we're getting somewhere aren't
we like
so like it's a really good dynamic with
them yeah it's just like the only reason
i don't think
the you know uh
i'm gonna butcher his name the dude from
far cry i only know him from john carlos
yeah
is because he in my opinion he wasn't in
the game enough to really validate
being in that game like that like he did
a good job when he was in the game but
he
he wasn't really in the game to that
degree if that makes sense to you guys
yeah so
like he was only really like cut scenes
and stuff so but but it boils down to
like let's not
um
over uh analyze the the
the thoughts right and look at it as
best performance when he was on the
screen
did he hold your attention he or she
those those type of things is is we
start to over analyze the thought
process of it and i mean i guess you can
say
your thought process is these other
characters were there more they gave
more to the game
but did they command the scene every
time they were in the game because more
times you're seen the less times you get
a chance to hit you might miss on this
scene but hit on that scene if every
time that he was on screen or he was
around
it hit then it's a difference you know
his best performance
so that's just all i'm saying but i'm
listening to your rationale and your
rationale has more credence to what i'm
saying and also i'm talking from a place
of ignorance because i haven't played
the game
hey hold on before we move on
okay yes sir i'm bugging i did not know
that this was john carlos esposito and
do the right thing and then you see it
right you see how he grew up from
breaking bad all the way through you
know from from from do the right thing
to breaking bad to the mandalorian and
countless other movies this man has
every time he's had a scene or something
he has definitely won these scenes and
he's he's a he's a fantastic doctor this
is actually a really
like
really tough performance like look
besides
like i personally feel like this year
has been you know in terms of like that
game it's not really existed this year
but i feel like there's been so much
good stuff that's going on this year
that
because that fallout isn't in here
because that witcher 3 isn't in here
because that zelda is in here that last
was two i feel like it's leveled the
playing field for everything else you
know what i'm saying
so like because i want to say yo the
chick from life is strange could win
this but at the same time i'm like
the chick from the resident evil village
had a movement so like
oh yeah
it's gonna be interesting man it's gonna
be interesting so we're almost done with
this all right so let best art direction
this is always a fun one
uh so best art direction the artful
escape death loop
cannon bridge of spirits
psychonauts 2
ratchet and clank ripped apart king take
take the stand man what's going on here
let me see
hmm
i like the artful escape def loop i
can't wait for game pass so these two
game pass lovable games here and then
ken is going to come to game pass too uh
cycle now wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
king yes
i need sources king
when we when is that gonna happen i mean
i need sources kind sir because i
figured that was the playstation
you know
oh that's a multiplayer game you talk
about kenna yeah that's multiplied sir
when that happened it'd been from the
beginning what was that
google that all right
google that google ads you know so so
right now microsoft is winning and then
you got to and you get a chance to play
uh ratchet and clunk next year on pc so
this is all microsoft stuff um
he is so terrible all right so bet our
our best art direction
all right what games can um withstand
standing test of time i'm gonna talk i'm
gonna tell you right now one of the best
art directions here is the artful escape
it is probably
so left that is right
it it allowed me to play because the
game
has a weird look and feel to it
and you playing your guitar brings the
world to life
um
death loop we've seen this art style
because this is their artwork i can
almost guarantee you that's not one yeah
it's that's the same art style they've
been doing for the last 15 years
right so we're we're talking about new
art direction okay so kenna bridges
spirits is going for the pixar type of
feel
but who outpicks ours ratchet and clank
nobody
right so
by that slash right there ken is in the
bushes um def loop is in the bushes
um the artful escape is standing
there toe-to-toe fighting uh ratchet and
clank and then we have cycle knots um
because i went to play the the first
psychonauts after playing psychonauts
two
and it just didn't withstand the test of
time the art direction did
but this art direction is a little bit
stronger because it's a lot more
polished and we get a chance to see uh
um i think his level of genius
there i i
don't believe it wins art direction here
um i'm not saying it's not a far
superior game to all the games that are
here
but this is we're not talking about far
superior game we talk about our
direction
it will be a toe to toe battle with
ratchet and clank rift apart um
and artful escape i don't think an indie
title gets uh get it over
aaa
in this category i'm going to have to go
with ratchet and clank ripped apart um
because i am not going to lie i'm a
sucker for ratchet and clank and i'm
waiting for a super black friday sale to
get it
uh let me get this five dollar ship shot
real quick uh we got it from fascio
seven i think phil should stop being
nice to uh uh jeff and who
selects those who voted which games goes
to which nomination category i don't
know who selects that
and i don't think phil is necessarily
being nice to the individual i think he
respects where the vgas is going and he
wants to be a part of it because there's
a lot of people who watch that i think
that's the biggest reason you're seeing
this because i mean it's it's doing more
numbers than the grammys and the emmys
and stuff so i mean you got to be a part
of that you got to
all right
uh anyone got anything to say about that
yeah i'll give my picks on it um
i'm a little torn between ratchet and
clank and kenneth the awful escape well
you know i kind of like a style like
this this doesn't look better than
ratchet and clank under zero
circumstances does this look better than
ratchet and clank uh something like
psychonauts
i haven't played it out i've only seen a
shout out to my boy glorious kev like he
streamed that he played and he beat it
yeah i just don't like the way i don't
like the way that that looks now
typically when i think that's cell
shaded and typically the cell shaded
stuff doesn't
it doesn't it ages very well
and that was psychonauts though it's
just something about it i just don't
like it um ratchet and clank game that i
do own i got an hour in it that game is
extremely beautiful every time that you
kill an enemy or you kill some robots
you see all the part of all the bolts
and stuff on the ground and everything
from those boss fights from pulling
yourself in and out of the dimensions
and everything all of that looked flat
on me like like superfly
and
i guess we'll get to it a little bit
later but like that's kind of
what i would lean on like that's
that's goldie like potential for me like
in terms of like it kind of gets
everything down from like
the voice direct you know what i noticed
when we went over the best voice actors
and actresses uh river wasn't over there
the girl who played rivets she was not
there
and it just hit me it just hit me
jennifer hale jennifer hill and
everybody was going guy got over her
performance so that's that's a little
odd to me but um but in terms of our
direction man
hey
y'all know
team blue baby tame blue ratchet and
clank man i already think and i don't
you can argue with either
i think this is between
kenna and psychonauts
i i think that
the arf will escape it could definitely
get it let me say those three kenna
arf will escape psychonauts i think
ratchet and clank looks nice but i don't
think it's like a huge different
direction than ratchet and clank one it
just looks better than ratchet and clink
one i don't think it's like the best art
direction something that looks good
something looks nice like can i as much
as i get annoyed by like the the some of
the
animations that happen in the game it
still is a very nice looking art
direction psychonauts 2
very nice looking art direction the
artful escape and i think that's what
they're going to really generally go
through storage is something that isn't
the norm and is a good way of going
towards the future in terms of if you're
not going to make something realistic
you can make it like this because it is
a nice way of doing things and i think
that's why it's neither kenneth the
artful escape or psychonauts 2.
i'ma put my stick down and say kenna
and the reason i think kenna once again
politics man gaming politics i think
they're going to want to give keno one
or two rewards
and i think this is one of those rewards
that they can give them
okay
because i do think psychonauts could win
this
but i do think personally there's a
chance psychonauts might win game of the
year maybe it's not a big one
but i do think that there is a chance
that psychonauts could win game of the
year uh so
i think we all pretty much agree on that
one do we need to go too much
into that one
no
all right so let's
let's talk about best narrative
story death loop that's not winning
it takes two
life is strange marvel guardians of the
galaxy it's the first time we've seen
that obviously we're not doing all the
the categories in psychonauts 2
hustle
tell me which one's which
i don't think i'm able to wait did i
play any games on this list the best
narrative right
i mean look if we if we talking about
story based games
i would have to say life is strange if i
had to pick one but and you got to
inform me about um well i know it takes
two like all right here's the problem
with dropping the game in like january
february the fact that you drop a game
that early in the year a lot of people
tend to forget about it but it takes two
like for a nice little minute before
fraternal came out it kind of was like
the talk of the town you know no doctor
trey but it was it was that it was a
little movement for a little while and
if you know anything about the story
it's about
two parents who are getting a divorce
and i'm not spoiling anything but
there's two parents who were getting a
divorce and
their daughter wishes that they kind of
would stay together forever so on and so
forth but there's always voodoo
come on man
he performs actual voodoo say blackmagic
yes sir oh my god
i don't i don't think it wins that i
don't think it takes two wins this uh i
mean
probably not but i mean if i had to pick
one i'm always going to be like feel
like the life is strange because of what
it covers just like um
last year that life is strange what what
was the microsoft title that everybody
was like
um um i know you're talking i'm uh
i cannot think of the name of it to say
in my life
but uh
our story or it was with the 20 it was
with the brother and sister and yeah i
mean
and things happen
oh yeah you're talking about um the same
life is strange type of thing i don't
know yeah i know what you're talking
about
put it in the chat put it in the chat uh
i know some one of you guys know it in
the chat put it in the chat of course
they do it's literally right there
yeah
tell me why you tell me
since you played beating review death
loop can you uh
tell me why that made one game of the
year or been uh win best narrative right
it's not gonna work narrative i don't
think it's going to i think it's got a
good narrative but i don't think that's
what i don't think that's what it's
going to stand on if it wins game of the
year i think its narrative is okay but
it's nothing special i think it's game
play and the mechanics of the games what
might make it one game of the year
its narrative is just we got to break a
loop we got to find out why to break the
loop then we got to break the loop i
literally just told you all of def loop
wow you know
not that like obviously there's other
stuff in between but that's generally
the narrative of death loop does that
sound like a best narrative thing for
you guys you know what i'm saying like
uh life is strange might get this and
part of me thinks that maybe marvel you
know because
i don't know how many things this is in
so marvel a lot of people liked marvel
so maybe marvel
so wait wait wait no no psychonauts love
uh at all because apparently that game
touches on a lot of uh say
deep and uh some dark issues so you
don't think uh psychonauts get that knot
but life is strange does too and i think
if they're gonna give it to life issues
they'll give it the life of strange over
psychonauts
okay okay well i mean i'm just going
based off of the categories and um
i don't see it it takes place
it takes two's a good game but i don't
think it's got a good narrative
because it's kind of everywhere as king
we played a little bit of it it's kind
of everywhere
um
[Music]
what i would pick okay so didn't play
def loop def loop seems
uh
like most roguelikes um a little
redundant in the strategy of what
they're trying to get you to get into
uh it's pretty much uh learning patterns
getting new weapons and stuff like that
and keeping these uh
these guns and stuff that's all next
move over um life is strange never
really held me
um marvel's guardians of the galaxy i
think they were trying to shoot marvel's
guardians of the galaxy in anywhere
in this uh this this
this whole award system uh because uh it
was a surprise
uh hit everybody that's played it said
they actually love it they thought it
was so far and removed away from the bad
taste that um marvel's avengers put in a
mouth pause
oh my god
that uh this game actually has legs to
stand on
um
it takes two attic and i played it i
think the narrative in it which is it's
beautiful uh you know this little girl
is uh going through watching the divorce
of her uh mother and father and how they
can just not love each other anymore and
she puts a voodoo spell on them and they
become these little dolls that are
animated uh and they have to go through
the house that they built together to
uh
work as a team to achieve something me
and eddie didn't get a chance to finish
it so i don't know the ending of that
story but i'm pretty sure
it could end good it could end
absolutely terrible they could still
stay divorced so they can actually find
some reconciliation
in that and that would be probably one
of the best narratives like for a family
game and being at a just hit game pass
might bring a lot more eyes and
awareness and votes on that game
um
[Music]
psychonauts
this is a the narrative of this game is
plaguing uh uh our um society at this
moment with mental illness and
to address it in this manner
with uh a cute lovable kid who have a
has a dysfunctional family but also is
um a detective
in this manner and he's dealing with his
peers and wanting to be accepted
uh
this game addresses so many different
issues that we have in society itself as
a whole at a proper time i think the
best narrative goes to psychonauts too
because i think it starts to uh help
people deal with
issues and identify issues that they do
have or they see in others that they can
come to grips with and talk about openly
so
um
i think this is a sneaky one here and
i'm gonna go with psychonauts too
because i love the narrative and what
they're trying to accomplish
um
okay
he said i didn't analyze the games in
the manager yeah yeah i didn't i didn't
i didn't um
one of the categories that i find
interesting um
you remember cyberpunk it came out right
and when it did
um we figured it was gonna be nominated
for stuff this year
i'm surprised that we don't see keanu
reeves in the best voice actor or
actresses uh category the best uh best
voice game was garbage
until they fix it that's the that's the
problem
you understand
the game can be whatever well what i'm
saying is
y'all saw how they was going over keanu
reeves they was losing their minds and
they was doing their whole thing and
they was
on them right
when the game dropped
i only got three and a half hours and i
just he just wasn't feeling it wasn't my
thing but you know i don't know
i would just figure the way that they
the media went gaga you know over him
like that you would figure he would have
been in there and i noticed that he
isn't there and it's um because i'm
looking just through some of the other
categories i see uh cyberpunk and best
score in music right so it was just i
don't know it was that was just
something i just thought i'd bring up i
just i just it stood out to me stood out
i don't think there's a snub per se well
it might be that is keanu reeves because
everybody seems to love them so it seems
like every category is tough
like
and it's i think a lot of it has to do i
really do is that
i think a lot of the lower tier games
that we normally get that you know when
you see them on the category you're like
there's no way you know what i'm saying
oh those aren't really here and it's
like i said like the the games that are
far above quality in terms of some of
these genres those aren't here either so
i think you're getting a lot more of a
middle term set of games so when it
comes to these categories you feel like
anything could win
right so let's this is open field
yeah so the
best
game direction
now we might argue about this one
best game direction definitely okay it
takes two returnal
psychonauts two
ratchet and clank rift apart king tell
me if you think any game shouldn't be
here or any game should be here best
game direction
huh
this is a strong category i mean this is
strong titles in this category they've
been trying to get a return into
something
and they've been
shout out to jeff i'm trying to force
this game on everybody
um
and i'm pretty sure this is that's
probably one of his personal favorite
games of the year
um
game direction
man this this is hard
this is hard because
you you want to this is where you we
lose our uh crowning a lord at it
because it's going to be a game that
we're not looking at in in the sense of
we're not looking at what direction what
do they mean
for direction
outstanding computer vision and
innovation in the game direction
and design you only tell you mine
you go
i
i think return is one in this yeah
it sucks because it's in the middle and
it's like staring you in the face like
you better pick it bro like you better
pick it because we have the best
direction bro
and
i'm like okay
i'm i'm by default i'm gonna say return
um you know being like i said talking
from a place of ignorance um
again
if i'm giving them money i'm not buying
that so
it from my heart
i i like the direction of psychonauts
it might be a year where psychonauts
action actually
sweeps all of these categories it might
be a year where he's the bell of the
ball
so you know what to hell with return i'm
going with psychonauts i think
psychonauts might be a secret destroyer
this year
and i'm going with psychonauts tim
schafer i'm rolling with you baby what
about you hustle
well
i'll be completely honest with you
king i'm glad you didn't take my answer
this time i think it is
i i think it is something like fraternal
um just in terms of in terms of it being
innovative um it this was a lot of
people's
myself included this was a lot of
people's first like roguelike game and
then the actual story even though i
couldn't make it to the end
right look this this is just too much
for me it's too much um even though i
couldn't make it to the end um there
were a lot of uh is it uh ambiguous
endings you kind of didn't know what to
like really make of
the first in there and then there is a
secret and then you kind of really don't
know
how to
figure it all out but
in terms of
in terms of innovation like when you've
an addict you know once you make it to
the house once you make it to the house
in the first volume you you know once if
you've got key to get in you can go and
explore and it's just bits and pieces of
that story is just told in a such a
different way so i'm going with return
on that but even though it's not
nominated for game of the year i think
it does take best game direction
and i guess we'll talk about
what needs to happen with with uh you
know with the game awards because i feel
like fraternal can't win this and then
not be nominated at all
um king psychonauts too though
i definitely got my eye on it because
like we spoke about it earlier like it's
touching on a whole lot of different
things that we're all going through and
there's certain things that yeah it
seems it seems so current as it yeah
like with the times and shout out to 10
shades fandom over there for that double
fine for that because that's
that's kind of a hard thing to do like i
can i can write a record today and like
if i write a song today will it be
timeless
one year from now five years from now
ten years yeah yeah like that's that's
not exactly the easiest thing to do but
i'm a real returner though because i
mean you know playstation blue on that's
i'm going to keep it real keep it real i
got you
um
i i i get what you guys are um
what you're saying on that i just
personally feel like
returnable out of all these things maybe
it takes two
and not even really that because there
has been co-op games before
yeah i think returno is one of the few
that's like
it can actually spawn something
different you know what i'm saying yeah
psychonauts there's been platformers
ratchet clank there's been platformers
it takes two that's a really good co-op
game
but there's
i mean they that studio only makes that
and death loop
maybe but like return i feel like on
there
it actually can do something unique if
it improves on the the roots that it was
made off of
and um
the rest of them i just see
i don't see that
okay we'll add it uh before before we
move on um you said it takes two right
um with joseph faraz and his team over
there you said that that's what they do
now let's let's talk about that that is
what they do and have we ever seen a
story in the co-op game and i want y'all
to educate me but have you ever seen a
story in a co-op game like that deep the
way it's dealing with certain issues
like that no that's all right i'm not
going to necessarily lean toward the
takes two but i wouldn't be surprised i
wouldn't be angry if that won that
because that that is something like that
that's different um and we know what joe
safari is like he made um
is it a tale of two sons or was it
the lost brothers or something like that
it came out like 2013 the way it was
like extremely story heavy and
everything so
you know what hey hold on i'm gonna
change my ass today it takes two
and a half
in a way out
hey that in the doorway i was hilarious
yeah that was hilarious and it changed
you know depending on what happened at
the end depending on who got who so yeah
no i mean i i think um
i think joe safar is in a team at uh
what's this what's that in the studio
hazelite studios
i think i think they got at least one
and i think it's that one i think it's
that one
all right so um
i won't be upset either be honest with
you as long as return doesn't get it oh
jesus
let's get this two dollar super chat
from king one supreme what uh what y'all
doing of microsoft game wins game of the
year hashtag book x
we are going
to have a very lit show
all right
all right
everyone
this is
it's
everyone this is the the grand finale
game
of the year
recognizing a game that delivers the
absolute best experiences across all
creative and technical fields
number one
death loop
number two
it takes two
number three metroid dread notice that
metroid is in any one that we've done so
far
thank you sir
number four
psychonauts ii number five ratchet and
clank ripped apart which i low key don't
think it deserves that and number one
the last one number six
resident evil village once again i don't
think we saw that in any other category
no
so
let's start
with hustle hustle do you agree with
everything on this list if not what
would you have replaced it with and who
do you think is gonna win the list that
we do currently have
all right well if i had to get one game
up out of here as y'all know i'm not big
on the scary game so resonate evil 8 can
get the poop
for the less horrifying of the evil
games returner i feel like returning
should be there but that's just my
honest opinion i was as we were talking
i was kind of looking around just to see
what metroid dread fell in the list and
i don't i'm not going to say that it's
not anywhere else but i didn't see it
nowhere else
in terms of like i didn't see it
anywhere else i'ma go back and just
double check triple check
this is the only place where i saw this
game there's the only place where we saw
samus kings i told you on downloads and
i guess like a month ago with mr
boomstick mm-hmm yourself incognito
don't buy buy it don't know my benefit
man shout out to lloyd metro i don't
know if he in the chat nobody buy that
joint man
like the people who were surprised i'm
like no this is
this is it and i guess that you know
jeff wants to give this the nod
i don't know what game is going to win i
got i'll make my guess but i'll tell you
what game ain't going win and that's
metroid and i say that respectfully i
said
i feel like this is i don't want to say
that this is ratchet and clank's for the
taking
because you know the media darling of
this group is definite
it is it just it just did
people was giving this game 10 10 out of
10's and they didn't really know why i
won't get into it but i felt like
oh look i felt like they was pushing
that agenda as a black man it's hard for
me to say that but you can kind of see
i can read tea leaves on that so you can
kind of see what that is just giving the
given the current state of society and
everything with everything that we've
gone through
yeah hey hey look i you know i i can see
that for what it is but honestly man
like we kept talking about it i i feel
like for me
you see the ratchet and clank that blue
or psychonauts 2.
um
yeah yeah i got it right i got it right
it takes two probably won't be there
because that game came out so early in
the year and now
while they had an impact
you know it kind of came and went
fraternal isn't here metroid dread man i
mean you know
sorry
sorry i'm just gonna be real sorry
king
tell me
if you would take something out to
replace it with something else and tell
me off the ones we have now
what are you kind of leaning towards
you're getting sleepy
very very
sleepy
now that i have you under my spell i
want you to look at the list again and
all you would see is psychonauts
[ __ ] you up now
if i had to yank something off that list
um honestly i would yank metroid dread
off yeah and i would put forza in that
place um
no 480p game should be up
[Music]
come on man okay so
you know y'all have your own little
award show for the for
for the iron paired games um
for the vaseline editions
um pause uh
listen this is the swan song for for
metroid i told people after finding out
metroid was uh nintendo's least uh
productive uh franchise in terms of
sales it threw me for a loop and then i
sat back and i thought about it and we
just had the muffin man on the other day
and uh
he
told me he can't stand metroid games
so i would respect the muffin man and
boot this game off my list
um and insert forza uh shout out to jeff
keagley for trying not to acknowledge
the true game of the year um
and i and i get it i get it uh you know
competition is none i hear that uh so
you got ratchet and clank and it's and
then this battle has been pitched a long
time ago this battle has been pitched
this whole summer all the way up until
now this battle has been pitched uh you
know ratchet and clank came out and
everyone
was all over remember the ssd
it can only be done it can only be done
and yeah
then we find out other stuff that's
gonna happen that's gonna break your
little hearts uh and then psychonauts
came out and microsoft dude just like
yeah
you know yeah i told you so man we got
our own platformer and our own
platformers doing more better stuff than
yours but
right so
lucky i might
i think i'm gonna go with ratchet and
clank uh
rift apart in the bushes and psychonaut
two for the win
actually i think psychonauts is going to
sweep a lot of awards this year
i think because of the history of it i
think because of tim schafer's hold in
the community his standing in the
community uh the group at double fine
um and and you know microsoft
bucks pushing it past the finish line
getting a game uh from a kickstarter
situation to a double a if not a triple
a uh stand the me the metacritic on this
game is ridiculous the art direction on
this game is ridiculous the fact that it
touches the mental illness aspect of
gaming and does it in such a way that is
nuanced and not overbearing and it keeps
you engaged at all times and has many
different aspects to do it i think game
of the year should uh be a game where
innovation is seen
um is there any innovation in any of the
other games no resident evil is the same
metroid uh introduces a new aspect of it
quicktime events wow that's innovative
uh it takes too not too much innovation
in this area but again it it does best
what it does a death loop
kind of see me uh you know from that
that prey type team that so i'm sorry
i'm gonna have to go psychonauts here i
think psychonauts wins game of the year
i think psychonauts sweeps a lot of
other categories as well i think it's
the toast of the town and i think you
see a change right here because this is
where the console wars actually hits a
crescendo microsoft walks off into the
sunset for the year of 2021
which building could you imagine
the year that they had building all the
way up to psychonauts taking game of the
year and microsoft like you know it's
like baby pointing to the stands and
hitting that home run boy it will be a
horrible holiday for these sony dudes if
this actually happens and i think jeff
might break down and cry this year i'm
going with psychonauts
i think that
there's no way
here's my thing
village might win it i think there's a
chance village might win
wow there is no chance ratchet and clank
went slightly
oh come on there is none man i think
psychonauts 2 could win this year and
next year before ratchet and clank wins
this year like it's just
i don't
look
it was a good game but that's all
i like they didn't really have no
talking power
like
i don't think metroid deserves to be on
this list i think that deserves to be
forced on horizon five
hell
rachel and clay might deserve to be
before as a horizon five like let's slow
down slow down slow slow down it's not
the metroid thing i get the petrol thing
i do get oh so we could take something
you don't like but we can't take
something you like gotcha yeah yeah yeah
hey look the metroid thing i understand
um i think i said my pick earlier but
def loop is
kind of
like i would like to say soccer
psychonauts too but that look just given
what the media has done about this and
seeing how they vote on these type of
things and seeing how it's weighed so
heavily and seeing how the fan vote is
only 10 of the uh
of the actual scale and in terms of like
weighing in terms of everything that you
vote for yeah i think it's definitely
real quick hey king i want to correct
you um i know we were slandering uh
metroid as we should by the way um
metroid prime 4 is being made by retro
studios i think retro studios have
started it but then it was given to
another studio and retro studios ended
up getting them backed by nintendo so
that i mean you know the metroid series
ain't over
but if it really don't sell that that
next time out i think uh metro prime 4
may be saying this is the last uh last
ride so to speak
let's get these let's get these two
super shots real quick quick two dollar
super superchat from king one supreme
microsoft has game of the year
nominations i thought xbox has no games
that is pretty funny man we got a ten
dollar surprise from smile
100 of media outlets including many
people per outlet and influencers across
the globe vote for the nominations the
nomination process can't get any more
fair than that jeff is not involved
do you have anything to say about that
jeff i understand that you had the super
chat and put smile and you had to put oh
my god
just to clear your name wow
just to clarify you're saying that smile
is a jeff
account
yeah
it's just like you know um
uh what's that kevin uh
duran
yeah yeah it's his burner accounts um
listen i understand that you watch the
swami to understand how i predict what
you're gonna do i understand jeff listen
you want people to believe that you're
not involved i get it don't touch the
money i see it
i hear it don't don't be around the
money you are separate from the money
let the money be over there so you'll
never get caught in the same room at the
same time jeff i've been playing this
game for years i truly understand if you
think your name ain't on the bill or you
ain't involved in some type of way i'm
not boo boo the fool but i do say this
and i do know that you have control i'm
going with psychonauts i love how he's
generally acting like he's talking to
jeff right now
because it is
so you know what's crazy
is it that far-fetched that it's not him
i'm pretty sure that's not him okay you
know why you know i say this addict
a lot of people used to think that
eminem never went back to the
underground after he became underground
king
until he was in there with a disguise on
getting back to the grunge getting back
to the trenches
we're in the trenches right now who's to
say he ain't down here you know
sharpening his skills let me hear what
the t what the people are saying let me
hear what attic got to say i truly
believe that he wants to tune in and
listen to what you know us a little old
people got to say no we don't probably
matter but
something might hit and he might be like
no i got a super chat
let's
let's let let's just clarify
yes you're saying
that jeff the person that runs the vgas
and whatever he does that's trying to
replace e3 is under our chat in a burger
account named smile
hey adam addicts you know what i'm a
kind of dick i'm going to contradict
myself uh friends of the show uh eric
hanshaw with with the backlog featuring
erica and shaw um jeff does listen to
that um he listens to it i forgot how
erica told me but we had that
conversation so he he got his head to
the street no i'm not saying he's
necessarily in the chat but
it wouldn't i guess maybe it wouldn't
surprise me that if he wasn't here right
now and
you know he sees the gentleman with the
glasses on and chinese he
sees the young wolf with the bed and he
sees the this other gentleman with the
la head on it maybe he's he might be
listening he might be listening that's
all
he said what they got to say about my
game awards let me see what the peons
have to say about my example so so just
out of curiosity
he came up with the username smile
that's his that's your thing because
he's gonna make him go cause he's right
now smiling at us
[Laughter]
they never find out it's me and jeff has
a great smile so
we have went into a complete rabbit
forever coming out of at this point
we got a two dollar superjet from jay
nicholas psychonauts two unique game
design and story game of the year
is a hundred percent behind you on them
me personally i feel like
i do feel like um
forza deserves to be on this list it's a
shame it's not but if i'm going off of
what's just on here
i think it's
i don't know why i think metro dread or
death luke like i don't think
psychonauts 2 for some reason i think
psychonauts 2 would deserve it but i
don't think i don't think i'm gonna give
it to him king i don't because i think
it
i feel like if
forza was able to get on this list
this wouldn't even be a discussion
because i do feel like in terms of
quality quality forza is the best one on
this list if it was on here yep
but it's not that's that's a different
alternative round that doesn't exist
i think for some reason the industry
really likes death loop
and i think that might be a thing that
they really go towards
then part of me thinks that village
might take it out of nowhere because
people like village
i don't want metro dread to win but part
of me thinks it might be that
and then part of me thinks maybe they'll
give it to psychonauts too
but then everything in me says they're
not giving it to ratchet
that's
that's why hey yo serious question
though um
like i'm trying to figure out how to
articulate this without sounding
disrespectful right
are they really still talking about any
of these games right now
respectfully and i say that respectfully
like i don't hear nobody talk about
resident evil helene rancher and clank
even though it's so with it so forget
all that psychonauts two came out in
what august right
we don't really we don't hear too much
on that um it takes two came out early
in the year that's you know not that
that's a bad game but it just came out
early in the year that loop you know
came out and i think september and they
got the high praise and that's it
probably has the highest praise metroid
dread are people still talking about
that
at all respectfully and i say that
respectfully
this is like
this is what i was saying at the end the
beginning of the podcast this is one of
those unique scenarios in the unique
years where there's not one game that is
so above the rest in quality
that it's it's that game we'd all know
as many games of the year the red dead
redemptions
twos the the last of us twos
uh you know those type of games god
award there's nothing like that so the
very top of the spectrum is not there so
you have you have a lot more of an even
playing ground throughout the year
but let me tell you
king
tell me how lit it's going to be if it
takes two
that'll be wins
i got a question i got a question
wait wait wait wait
no no
did
okay spider-man miles morales got
nominated last year i was about to say
something is missing off this list and i
was like i don't know what it is because
it was it was bothering me it was
bothering me it got nominated last year
all right i'm not upset behind this i
kind of know what you got
nominated last year
um
i don't remember a second team
i would like to say if spider-man miles
morales got nominated last year demon
souls if it got nominated for anything
it did and nominated last year i'm just
not sure for what though because you
know those drop on the same day
so i'm sure joe was nominated for
something i don't know if i won anything
though that was just i don't know like
that just stuck up to me just looking at
uh just looking at this this list here
you know what you know what the greatest
thing about this is king
as long as ratchet and clank doesn't win
we win
oh man
that's kind of crazy right
death wins that's an xbox game it takes
two wins that's on game pass
metroid wins that's not a playstation
game psychonauts win that's an xbox game
ratchet and clique wins damn wow yeah
that's that's it evil village wins
that's a multi-player
that's wild oh oh man regardless what
happens as long as ratchet and clank
doesn't win
we win
all right
they're speaking for themselves ladies
and gentlemen uh no we're speaking for
him too we're speaking for him oh man oh
man i guess i'm an xbox fan and i'm
speaking to that addict that is uh
segway boys in the building speaking of
xbox uh i don't know if y'all heard but
uh there was a certain beta that dropped
it but pretty much made the internet
stop what it was doing
go to the microsoft store hop on the
xbox one x's and their series consoles
and download a game a little a small
game a small game called a halo infinite
can we talk about it
yes we could talk about it king did you
get a play at any last night
yo so check it out right um i started
playing
uh
with uh chris and the team and um
my son hopped on
no no no i started playing with chris on
the team and chris had to go to work
chris left out and then i was playing
with wilmy scream and tie guy travis
jumped in shout out to tai kai travis uh
didn't get a chance to play no destiny
with thai guy but would definitely got a
chance to play some halo infinite
multiplayer with thai guy
yo we were running rub shot
over these dudes playing oddball and
stuff like that and all these oh man
oddball is so much fun these games are
so much fun absolutely incredible
um how big team battle and stuff like
that is is uh situated so remember i
didn't play any of the flights right so
i'm coming into the situation fresh face
old school let's see what's up let's see
what we got here
all right so i got out of uh the joint
with will me scream and tie guy because
i had a play date with my son
and uh
he gets on we get and i lock the room
and we uh go to big team battle
and we're playing uh my son is 10 years
old he'll be 11 in january
and
we had such a blast
father and son moment uh
i'm getting kills and we're you know
going to see who can get the most kills
for the match and i at one point in time
i had like 24 kills and he had like 12
kills and he's like oh i gotta catch up
daddy so i'm telling him about the drops
and stuff like that and we find in the
sniper perches and we're we're getting
in and um into the ships and flying up
and and shooting her it was so much fun
it brought back all the feelings of halo
it didn't feel like it was a man out of
place like captain america it felt like
it was never left
and i'm telling you
now
free to play whoever yelled out free to
play in that room to get this game
everywhere
and now also i gotta say i'm
diametrically opposed to it being
launched yesterday i'm at odds as a
business person in the business mind i
would have said hell no because i wanted
to see forza reach this crescendo reach
its peak uh to see how far can actually
get the eyes on it but um in further
conversations with uh you know my iron
lord brothers
and uh other people the cross
pollination of both games
pulling from uh one aspect of people who
will never get a chance to play it to
the other aspect of people that want to
engage and and you might cross-pollinate
from
halo to uh forza
uh i think microsoft looked at it as an
opportunity they can't miss eight
million eyes on one game we need to pull
eight million of these people over this
way if we possibly can
and if not more and then you know vice
versa
it's a phenomenon now
it's it's it's it's really
they're really doing it right now and
i've i don't think we've seen microsoft
hitting like this since the heydays of
360.
you know um they ramped up with the xbox
and
this multiplayer
hits everything
did anybody find it weird that it was no
performance it was just graphic mode
right now
and was that the test bandwidth uh
per se who what's your opinion on that
choice to just have it at uh graphics
mode and not perform it
okay i can't speak to that because i
didn't know addict did you play this
game on a console or pc
console
okay so maybe you can speak to x i
didn't i didn't know that there was a
difference like you know i'm pc dude
over here so right i didn't know
look man i played on the frame rate that
was default i didn't really check too
much into that i did put the field of
view all the way up i think one point
yeah i think it's it's a solid
experience but i i do question a little
bit in terms of how they're monetizing
the free to play just a little bit
because i i'm a little bit concerned
where i can't even change the color of
my spartan without you know
uh digging into my pocket and doing
something all right what what to see i
changed my color with with nothing no no
money no when i tried to it's it was all
locked okay well okay what you were
trying to probably do was trying to uh
go to areas where
you can unlock all that stuff by playing
right all that stuff is available to you
by playing and getting through your
tears if you buy the season pass a lot
of stuff can get to you a lot quicker
but you have to still unlock that
through actual playing the same way you
know through destiny you unlock the
season pass there's an extra tear that's
under the bottom that you can get these
rewards down here if you didn't have the
season pass you can still achieve uh
this stuff that's up here it's it's
pretty consistent in when i say that um
across the board for all free to play
games i'm playing this game called the
art of war legacy on um my phone
and if i brought the season pass for it
i unlocked a tier that i can get extra
perks but i still get my regular perks
if i don't unlock that tier so nothing
is really excluded i just get a lot of
things quicker so i think i understand
exactly what you're talking about when
you're talking i think
the biggest reason isn't really the
the issue that i'm having with
the you know the options that you have
at launch i think my issue
is the progression system
right because i played for like
five hours and i'm level two and a half
almost three
so to me that's wild but
yeah to me i'm sitting here looking at
this and i put this amount of time into
it and i feel like i got nothing for it
i'm looking at all this stuff you get
and i'm just thinking myself
how much time do they expect me like
this is worse than destiny king like
this
this is
this needs to be fixed
i want to speak on that
i want to speak on that actually um
brian gerrard who is the community i'm
gonna make sure i get his title right
he is the community director over there
three four three um in terms of the
level progression and everything
long story short he heard the outcry
they're working on it um if you guys
have any like bugs or glitches that you
have to report um you go to aka that ms
slash halo support just in case you see
somebody warping through a wall or
something or whatever the case may be
yeah so they are looking into this um
shout out to my homie eric empire he had
tweeted this out oh he had uh put the
tweet in the dms that i'm a part of
earlier um let's see what was the other
thing what was the other thing
can you say something then i had kind of
forgotten about it oh okay well i want
to talk about this on pc
i played this at 120 frames 4k 120
frames per word
i said word because we can't yeah yeah
okay okay yeah i didn't want to speak on
the pc side of things um
it seems like it stutters a little bit
it seems like it's the same problem i
think this 343 issue because it's the
same problem when i was playing um halo
reach which is on my channel now with
contradiction and omega zx-456 right but
i pretty much had to cap it at 60 frames
in order for it to run fluidly now i
paid all this money for my pc so i want
to pay that at the
max the way i want to play it however it
seems like it's a little stuttering
there's a little hiccup but you know
it's day one launch or this is the first
day lunch oh i wanted to address that
point too
from a business standpoint this is their
super mario i've gone on the iop and the
writing platforms and i've said yo
shigeru miyamoto would never nintendo
would never let super mario go out like
this they had to launch it on the 15th
even though that and i'm old enough to
remember can't show you you know what
necessarily people wasn't feeling halo
like that but they wasn't feeling halo
in the very beginning like that they
weren't they weren't on it like that in
the very beginning however however it
grew legs and we are where we are now so
it had to drop on that day when we saw
like the early leaks of the console that
halo console and the halo controller i
think you got it yes sir i got the
console as well
okay
man sir i tried i tried my damn um now
but when we saw the release date like
for all intents and purposes the game
was supposed to release this thing oh
the whole thing was supposed to release
this day um it was a blessing in
disguise that it got delayed last year
um up until this year it wasn't supposed
to be december 8th it was supposed to be
november 15 2021 for the 20th
anniversary and i would have been super
dope however however um
while i'm like loving this game i got an
hour and a half in with the
troubleshooters and the sus core shout
out to alex and there's people over
there right there are a couple of things
that i do want to address
all right well one one why the game deal
worked fine outside of that stuttering
issue or whatever that lag issue
whatever that issue was with the with
the frame rate right of
playing our ball
y'all know like for me i got my settings
on recon so this feel like halo 3 to me
aka it feels like home to me that's
that's my favorite halo that's the one
that i love the most
when you punch somebody when you got the
skull in the head it supposed to be an
insta kill oh no is it too hit now yeah
yeah that sucks no i'm like yeah i don't
like it i don't like it so i was finna
take out the i swear because i got it on
my stream last night i was finna take
out a whole stream i hit dude i said
okay yeah he's still up i said oh man
he's still up so yeah i ended up killing
him but i ended up dying but that's not
the point that's not the point right the
other thing was capture the flag capture
the flag for me while of course it's fun
and it's super amazing and i did play uh
one of the last flight tests yeah yeah
oh they got something with this
multiplayer boy if this don't don't win
ongoing game next year then
somebody paid somebody else because it's
destroying fight working with all these
folks you don't get an instinct you
don't get a uh insta kill with the flag
kill no more either
i'm like yeah i think people going cry
out now i i think okay i think
that
had to be addressed in the form of
oddball you would be too dominant right
because i i did it too and i'm used to
it as well right
i cracked the hell out of dude and i'm
thinking he was gonna go down and i was
like okay and then i hit him again and
me and thai guy was talking about it
because you know i think that was one of
our best matches
but um
we were talking about it that it's a
double hit now instead of a single hit
and once once we get past that part then
you know you gotta crack them slide to
the side crack them again
it's not like you can't stop you know
shout out to jay barry throwing the
elbows um
it's not like you you can only you know
swing once so it's a well-timed hit
because it gives a push back and then
you can you know dip over to the left to
dip over to the right and crack them
again
um
one thing i do think when it comes to
the uh the xp
i think they're waiting for the the
campaign
because if it's tied to it like how
destiny is we get the majority of our xp
when it goes to our season pass through
uh doing uh stuff through your campaign
and then you can get xp individually
from different vendors
as far as you know uh shacks and stuff
like that uh and you know vanguard have
their own xp so i think they're going to
start moving it in that aspect because
we don't know uh
infinite in his totality and how that we
do uh see commerce of the game and how
we can uh uh split uh xp through
different tasks that will be in the game
so i think the uh the outcry at this
moment is from a point of not
understanding what their total package
is in delivering uh halo infinite is in
totality right now we have a small
aspect of it so maybe that large uh
other component to it helps us flesh out
how the xp is deviated throughout uh the
game because like addict i've uh played
for a couple hours and i made it to
level one and i was like wow that is the
longest that i've ever played to get to
a level one but at the same time when
you play those multiplayer games you
just do one match and you level one and
you level one yeah and that's what we're
used to
but
maybe there's something else behind that
and i feel and i understand what you're
saying attic uh because if they if
they're forcing like the the multiplayer
uh season pass on you some guys might
think so
uh you don't have to purchase that you
can grind for it and it's for the fomo
package
you know a lot of dudes want to do
things earlier they want to stunt
package the stunt fomo package
[Music]
man they got a lot of stuff
yeah they do oh wait i do want to speak
on the customization even if you don't
buy anything
the customization from you know i had a
chance like just waiting in between
matches and everything yeah it's it's
like super robust considering like i
didn't have a chance to like fully look
at it it's a lot going on um i saw like
you can put like a little i don't know
what you call them but like a little
hang tag or hang emblem like i'll try to
get ar and all that yeah that to me is
dope like i i wouldn't necessarily pay
for that i'll grind to get you know that
type of stuff yeah that to me is like
super dope and you know man if
you know if microsoft for work day magic
or what they should do what they should
do they should do like um like a six
degrees of separation like some type of
universal type thing that i want to see
like see it thieves content in that game
i want to see
yeah yeah it's because it make the most
sense i want to see doom guy on the end
of my little ar when i'm shooting
that that's that's really what i mean i
think we will uh a lot of
cross-pollination
uh from other aspects for different
medias uh movie uh stuff like oh the new
eternal stuff is coming out you can have
that inside the game the same way
fortnite has uh
emerged the two genres they've done it
with music they've done it with movies
they've done it with pop culture
so um this has that aspect hopefully it
can reach those heights where uh the
licenses and and all type of promotions
can run through halo to actually fund it
into a different manner and to give us
different things so
i think people need to keep their eyes
on stuff what is your
best new weapon mine is the switch up
shotgun shout out to ty
guy travis uh we both like that new
switch up shotgun
dual mode like it has two different uh
uh shot options which which one is this
yours
um
to be honest with the king
i don't like none of the new stuff
okay
i stick with my br my ar like okay
because that ar is so effective it's
good
i don't feel like the need to pick
anything up like because that ar like if
i'm close to you
i'm i'm i'm i'm a you you're gonna get
it like but yeah
clearly obviously i'm not saying i'm
like the greatest halo player but
i just to me maybe i need to like break
more of mental barriers i'm willing to
try new things
but i really enjoy
the you know that that they are i think
it's a very solid foundation i think
i think that this game is
i think it's gonna do really well man i
really do i think it's got a lot of
uh energy i think it's going to
really push past
people's limits that people think this
game has
i don't think there's a ceiling on this
game
i think i think they could easily
contact you know um
a variety of different things you know
they're putting uh the the ninja armor
on there i think they could easily
do a viking one next they can do
anything with all their franchises they
can put the doom outfit in there like
anything goes you can i wouldn't be
surprised if you start getting killed by
a cortana skin in a couple years from
now like yeah absolutely absolutely um
as far as new weapons for me
um
i i don't i don't particularly have a
favorite i do have a uh i have a
complaint about
an old favorite though the rocket
launcher that rocket launcher takes so
long to reload when you gotta reload it
it takes
that's forever but when it hit though
i got double kill last night with that
joint ball i was not playing
um one of my favorite modes is a
stronghold yeah well y'all don't really
know because we haven't we haven't had
the chance to game together hopefully
that'll change with the halo stuff um
i'm an objective uh based guy like i
don't i don't like like tdm you know i
can i can rock with the ar because that
ar is improved boy and the reason why
i'm gushing over it so much because the
ai used to be useless you used
sir
sam let me make my point you throw me
off
that's my point
yeah that ai used to be garbage man but
like it seemed like they fixed it and it
was like that in the earlier flight too
or the last flight that i played so it's
good to see that you know because like
like attic was saying like yo like you
you swap the ar for the be off real
quick yeah the br is crazy yeah yeah
yeah that's that's what you run with
but outside of the uh the rocket
launcher being super slow um i don't
think that i've had the opportunity to
pick up other things um
capture the flag and big team battle
it's always a load of fun
stronghold like i love stronghold um we
play uh strong mode and slay night
that's up on my channel too oh that's up
on my twitch channel
that's different right
it hit different and but i love like
stuff like that like i love that type of
mode um the sniper rifle is always going
to be classic you know even though i'm
super good with it sniper rifle is
always going to you know do what it's
supposed to do and unlike in gears you
can bang bang bang bang bang bang bang
like john with the spoon may he rest in
peace yeah you know what never mind my
fault y'all don't get that reference
however
exactly
not it's it's not like unlike the way
it's one shot and then you gotta reload
and there's one chapter below so like no
no this this this game here because it's
not bolt action it's actually uh a
sniper rifle that is uh feel augmented
ready for combat training yeah so it was
really good thank oh man i can't wait to
see like the highlights and that's
actually um and i'm glad i brought the
highlight thing up that's actually
working to youtube not making content
but like the first thing that brought me
to youtube was halo 3 montages like you
throw a grenade across the map you stick
people and yeah i mean you get headshots
with the br and i used to think people
was cheating i was like this ain't
possible but it is yeah
it is
oh oh man real quick real quick um this
is why this game is super fun i have not
adjusted my controls i'm on recon
controls but you know how you gotta
adjust like the sensitivity on the
sticks and all that haven't done
anything controller on this joint now
yeah oh op though that joint look it's
not it's it's not the accuracy of a
mouse but the aimlessness is so heavy
it's still super heavy though so yeah
well
i got a chance to use the new uh halo
elite 2 controller
um
i'm talking about the fearless game
when my wife saw it i put it in her hand
she's like oh no no no no this is a
controller
she was like oh man this this thing is
really good
it's it's it's def definitely worth the
the price of admission um
i i
i noticed too
on the 15th another batch of halo
xbox series x
consoles went up uh for sale
instantly sold out um
you know instantly sold out
wonderful stuff
i think
they understand the importance of halo
and i have to thank craig
for doing what craig did
craig was a wake up moment at microsoft
and if they didn't seize it in the
manner that they did and if they had
stayed steadfast in in in
in old ways
we wouldn't have what we have now and i
think those those
that ability to
be fluid in this business
is a benefit for them because to come
right after forza with something of this
polish this level of uh dexterity that
it does show
um it looks like it's built for the long
haul and this is without the campaign
everybody is going to be a little bit of
uh infinite fatigue multiplayer wise by
the time december 8th shows up
and that's when that campaign drops and
that's when the world takes notice of
what halo infinite is trying to become
and trying to be because if that
is truly supposed to be the games of
service type of game that's going to
live inside game pass
attic i think next year
that ongoing game
to take that spot will be halo
that's interesting man i'm kind of
curious
exactly what's going to happen with the
future of halo
especially when the relaunch happens and
we see these games full come out uh you
know because it's still technically a
beta
yep i think the reason they did the beta
thing is because they still want to be
able to say that the game came out at
the same time and still hold out to that
so i think this is pretty much the game
you're going to see
uh launch at that day maybe with some
adjustments they'll probably be doing
some adjustments between now on the
release but you know i think it's a
solid experience and i hope we see more
man but you know definitely going to
wrap this up we went on a little bit too
long than we normally do
one more yeah
a friend of the show miranda sanchez did
a very compelling piece about her first
i believe four hours on ign.com
so if you guys oh well it's on youtube
it's on youtube so just make sure y'all
go check that out that actually has me
excited for the story um
i'm actually you know i know game pass
and all that i'm copying this game on
steam based off of the fun that i'm
having off of the multiplayer i'm not
gonna lie i'm gonna pay the 64. man and
if this game lives up to everything that
she says and everything that i think
that it's gonna be
you know
halo could possibly admire it's the
throne gears which i don't know if
that's possible but yeah i mean like it
very well could do that so i'm
definitely looking forward to it um
spiritual reboot i can't wait to jump
back down i'll be honest with you but
i'm not having a blast for multiplayer
yeah i definitely hear that so we're
gonna go right to this up real quick
all right king what what what where are
the people find you man
well you can find me fridays nights
at 9 00 p.m on uh dcx channel uh with
the legion of doom where we talk all
these illustrious statues you can look
into the pockets of a couple of
millionaires that are broke
um
because uh
our passion actually uh keeps us uh on
our toes we talk comic books we talk
movies we talk pop culture
um everything that has to do with geek
culture everything that as uh you know
us you know
as as as
as kids grown grown baby men
and women you know uh that's what we do
then you can catch me at iron lords
podcast
sundays at 11 a.m during football season
which is thankfully coming to a close
and we'll get back to our
wonderful
1pm that attic and i will be happy for
[Applause]
[Music]
so we don't have to do that anymore we
can actually get some good rest um but
no the attic this is so much fun uh i
almost overslept buddy uh
i thought it was at 6 pm i'm sorry
you're fine man so hustle
what's going on man what do you have
going on
well
i made a return back to twitch in terms
of streaming so i will be doing that um
2022 i'm gonna have more of a schedule
that's like in the making um hopefully
this weekend hopefully saturday i will
give my impressions of the halo
multiplayer but i mean hey y'all heard
it here like spoiler alert the joint
fire spoiler alert but i'm gonna throw
some gameplay behind and i'm gonna throw
it up on the channel hopefully this
weekend if not monday so you know just
look forward to that um hustling
motivators everywhere um i've been show
shout out to everybody on twitter right
i've been seeing like a lot of people
posting their game play i saw my man bam
bam i saw a kiss move i saw quite a few
people just posting the game play man
and you see what happens when you got
like a super good game to play like
ain't nobody counsel one out this joint
and the people who are
a little upset because they probably
don't have nothing to play on their
their uh preferred console of choice i
would just say this
hop on that pc hop on that xbox and come
play hello with us though like
we're welcome man come on everybody come
on let's let's let's let's make a go at
it because battlefield was slipping yeah
oh king we didn't even mention that now
battlefield is lit i played that
battlefield that battlefield lit boy 10
hours i won't say it was oh jesus yeah
yeah it is it's available for 10 hours i
won't say that it's bad i would just say
that
people are you know people hate ten
dollars pay the time concern
hey
hey i mean game game pass shortly i
guess but you know it is what it is it
is what it is you know but
things things stumble out the gate um a
lot of people ain't necessarily pop
positive on battle um what's that the
other one call of duty either yeah
the cookies is for the taking now the
cookies for the taking baby
cookies
don't forget chat this friday at 5 p.m
most likely i will be streaming shinobi
hopefully it'll be friday i can't
guarantee that but definitely follow the
iron ironlord's podcast twitter handle
because that is where i will announce it
but anyway i appreciate it for coming
through man we will see you next week
and until next time this gaming added
king david and huss